Kyah fantastically strong female role in
this film for you Emanuel and the truth
about fishers and also the first time
view American accent what was it like
playing both those things it was really
cool I mean I loved strong female roles
I could never see myself playing just
the girlfriend or you know just the love
conquest or anything like that I liked
meaty roles I like intelligent roles for
women and this like spoke volumes to me
as soon as I read it and as far as the
American accent goes it was great and
for me to like push myself because I've
never done it before I had an amazing
voice coach who taught me loads about it
technically and you know all the ins and
outs of it and it was a great skill to
pick up and hopefully it wasn't too bad
he working with Jessica Biel and also
with Alfred Molina in this film it was
that like great act incredible I mean
with Alfred I had to kind of really try
and keep concentration in the scene
because I wanted to just watch him he's
got this amazing power as an actor way
you just want to watch him and you just
completely believe everything that's
going on and I you know I totally wanted
him to be my dad by the end of it okay
please just adopt me he's genuinely one
of the nicest men in the world it's so
kind he's still got that British humor
he's very sarcastic and funny and you
just kept everyone smiling all day and
the same with Jesse like she's an
incredible role model to me now you know
she really mothered me and talked to me
and made sure I felt safe and
comfortable all the time it was a great
experience to out with them
of course in this film you play a kind
of confused teen don't you and you spent
a lot of you time on camera playing
teens and skins of course and that is
coming back at it for serious southern
tell us what you're looking forward to
about returning to what something I
guess you maybe thought you would have
never returned to yeah I never ever
thought I would return to at all and I
didn't really want to until I found out
that they really wanted to focus this
mini film on that kind of age you go
through where you're not a teenager
anymore but you're not quite an adult
and you don't you're trying to work out
what it means to become an adult and I
was totally going through that in real
life so it felt important for me to go
back to skins because it had been such
an important part of my life and a part
of me growing up to then experience that
again with them and tell that story
because I couldn't really think of any
other mainstream program that had done
that I think a lot of people want to
focus on University and then you're sort
of late 20s and stuff but that really
kind of early time where you you're kind
of lost you know completely overwhelmed
and you removed
city and all these things and then I
wanted to go back and work with Lily
Lovelace again I really wanted to work
with Charles Martin the director again
so for me I really I can't wait to
better run to the way is going from that
TEENhood to adulthood isn't and you
could have done that in a way on camera
yourself haven't you what are you taking
from your own life experience back into
skins now I think we all take something
it's such an important time and it's
totally like yeah I do know the story
time if he goes down is completely
different to what I've gone down
obviously but I think it's still there
the friendships you know things that you
thought were majorly important when you
were 14 suddenly aren't anymore and kind
of want to focus on work and different
things so I kind of took that aspect so
what can we look forward to with the new
series of skins all there's a lot
there's a lot going on and she was
starts working the city and makes her
way up and she's living with Miami so
it's all about the balance of their
friendship I finally want to ask you've
got a huge potential franchise on your
hands as well with the Maze Runner how
exciting is it to be involved in that
I'm so excited it's a dream come true
and it's a really really cool trilogy
and there's no kind of lovey dovey
romancing stuff it's very much hardcore
it's about survival and it's about
people finding out what's going on and
conspiracies and it's very intelligent
and I'm absolutely honored to be a part
of it I cannot wait to start filming
will Poulter and Thomas brodie-sangster
yeah yeah really good British cast there
as a all playing American Louisiana yeah
in Louisiana for ten we are out in like
a couple of days so I'm really excited
we look forward to seeing that of course
brilliant look with a manual and the
truth about fishes it's fantastic film
and four skins as well so much to look
forward to for you thank you very much
you